Imagine a world where we get what we all
deserve: A good death.
Nothing seems much different. The world is much the same as it is now.
People do the same sorts of things,
have much the same joys and pains. They're born, they grow up, they work, they play,
have families, love argue, enjoy
their brief time on Earth.
And die.
It's just that if you go to the outskirts of
any town there's a new facility there.
It looks like a Medical Center. It is, in a
way. A well-designed building with nice
landscaping and a free car park. If you
go inside you'll discover what's going on.
The receptionist can explain.
There are leaflets too. Everything is well ordered
and calm.
Doctors, psychologists, counsellors and nurses work here.  But so too do specialists lawyers.
This is the "Good Death Centre", provided on the National Health Service.
Those who don't want to descend into the indignity of extreme dementia, or doubt the ability of
palliative care to ease their exit from
life, will come here when the time is right.
They'll choose the moments of
their own deaths. Most of us have a death
plan and a living will now. It's a great
comfort to know that the option exists
if the going gets too tough.  We've heard
euthanasia for pets for a very long time
but before the good death centres we
forced our friends and relatives to
endure months and sometimes years of
agony and indignity against their will.
For what? They now seems so cruel, so
unnecessary, so pointless.
Of course there are safeguards. No one
gets to use the facility without
thorough psychological examination and
counselling. This choice is only for the
sound of mind and those who have
demonstrated a genuine desire to die by
these means. You need a good reason such
as a painful terminal illness
or the first signs of dementia. Consent has to be informed. Life is much better now.
It's reassuring to know you don't have
to endure it even when you've lost the
power to take your own life.
I have my own death plan.
If I don't die my sleep, I expect to die in a Good Death Centre.
It's a comforting thought. You should think about it.